hey guys it is Friday again which means
I've got five news this week very that
stories in gaming to get you all caught
up on what's going on the NPD Group have
dropped their console sales charts for
july and the ps4 has come out on top
july marks the third month running that
the ps4 has outsold the xbox one sony
thanks to their fans and noted that the
batman arkham knight ps4 bundle has been
a big seller for them in the US the
company said they also expect the
limited edition destiny the taken king
ps4 bundle to be a hit with fans when it
comes out on sep tember 15 xbox one did
take the lead in console sales back in
april however the MPD report showed
eight fifty six percent decrease in last
gen console sales from 2014 to 2015 and
ps4 and Xbox ones are selling almost
fifty percent better than ps3 and xbox
360's did after being on the market for
21 votes respectively
bungie have spent even more time this
week trying to convince you that the
taken King expansions the Destiny is
totally worth that hefty forty dollar
price tag community manager Eric Osborne
told IGM that the expansion costs double
that of the last two because it includes
a whole lot of content he explains I
don't have any trouble saying that the
taken king is well more than twice as
much content as the dark below the story
is great they're seven crucible
multiplayer maps there's three brand new
straight we've got the Dreadnought which
is not just a big new destination to
explore there's tons of little secrets
and things you can collect and more guns
and more gear and exotics the expansion
also has three revised strike missions
with the taken incorporated into them
and the Kings full raid the PlayStation
Plus vote to play program is now
officially live that means you'll get to
pick the next free game you'll be
offered with your subscription you can
head over to the PlayStation stores plus
section and cast your votes now
september's choices include our mellow
zombie Viking and from home which was
previously since the exclusive moti
extends until August 24 at 830am and you
can check out trailers for each of the
options on gamespot for those of us who
didn't like having free time anyway
fallout shelter has now landed on
Android the game is still completely
free to play with lunch boxes available
to buy for 99 cents each or 40 for
twenty bucks I don't agree with
microtransactions personally but there
are few things that's exciting is
opening a harder fallout shelter lunch
box after putting out like 50 fires and
seeing what you thought in any case
people must be buying them because the
festa made 5.1 million bucks off the
game in just the first two weeks after
its launch despite claiming that they
to make money off it another full 18
years Bethesda have been crusading all
week to try and get secretly filmed
fallout 4 gameplay off the internet for
the most part they were succeeding save
for the videos hosted on pornhub the
shoddy looking footage lived on the
adult website for the better part of
this week before eventually being taken
down due to a copyright claim the 7
minute gameplay video which was recorded
behind closed doors at Gamescom showed
the protagonist mowing down girls using
iron sights access and computer
terminals lock-picking and interacting
with this hip boy let me know down in
that comment box what you cared about
this week and if you reckon Destiny's
taking to the expansion is going to be
worth the 40 bucks this week on site I
cover off on five unbelievable sgdq
speedruns on the chip and we crack into
the rocket league supersonic fury GOC
that is everything I want to tell you
about today be sure to have yourselves a
lovely weekend and I will catch you
again on Monday